[Music]
waste
piling up disposable protective
equipment
plastic packaging initially there had
been a hope that the slowdown in the
world economy
would be good for the planet air traffic
almost stopped completely
cruise ships were stranded in port and
industrial pollution was reduced
but the pandemic has had negative
consequences for the environment
too the world was already drowning under
a sea of plastic waste
but the pandemic has made the situation
worse
[Music]
face masks can stay in the environment
for up to 450 years
it takes that long before they turn into
invisible microplastic
so this issue is quite serious
as the human toll of the coronavirus
mounts and the world economy struggles
to adjust
to the new normal the wider impact on
the environment
is only now starting to become apparent
the global medical emergency has
presented an opportunity to check on the
health
of the planet as controversial new
lockdown measures kick in in the capital
madrid
is our report from spain
[Music]
leliana aldegar is pulling plastic waste
from the river segura near the spanish
city of alicante
there's heaps of garbage everywhere
the problem is that plastic is very
light so it's easily swept up by the
wind and flows down rivers
where it ends up in the sea
liliana says spain's plastic waste
problem has gotten worse
since march when the coronavirus
outbreak began
everything's got worse since the
pandemic we'd started using less
disposable plastic packaging
but now spanish people are buying even
more plastic wrapped items because
they're scared of getting infected
disposable plastic gloves are common in
supermarkets
they're light and easily swept away
the pandemic has led to a waste crisis
now
even environmentally conscious consumers
feel safer buying plastic wrapped
products
here 200 kilometers further south near
the city of ameria
spanish farmers are growing bell peppers
and melons under vast plastic sheets
some of them dispose of old sheets
illegally but catching the culprits is
tricky
we managed to find a former farmer who
was willing to talk about the problem
[Music]
growing crops is their livelihood but
images like these
tarnish our image a few farmers are
ruining everyone's image
[Music]
and his colleagues from the marine
conservation organization promar
study what happens to plastic waste in
the sea
they take samples to have them checked
for tiny plastic particles
these substances are toxic they're
poisonous chemical products
that break down in the sea we shouldn't
only be concerned about plastic bags
floating around
the tiny plastic particles you can only
see under a microscope
are even more dangerous
paco's team have their latest sample
examined at a lab
and they find yet more plastic particles
this plastic passes through the food
chain through fish
and ends up in our bodies too we also
absorb
plastic waste in the sea poses a serious
health risk to humans and animals alike
that's why liliana aldegar spent so much
time cleaning up
she says the pandemic shouldn't serve as
an excuse for us to produce even more
garbage
she says protecting the environment also
keeps us healthy
[Music]
the two are connected if we destroy the
environment
we also endanger our own health we are
seeing this now during coronavirus
pandemic
we're not thinking ahead not protecting
the environment
and not treating animals like we should
the european union wants to cut back on
single-use plastics
but these days due to the pandemic the
very opposite is happening
it takes some 500 years for these
materials to decompose
so they'll be with us for generations
well let's speak to jan peter schemmel
he's ceo of the erko institute
for applied ecology here in berlin
thanks a lot for joining us so we saw in
our report people there
choosing plastic packaging for their
food because they think it's safer
given the pandemic i mean is there a
danger that this pandemic is making our
day-to-day lives
less ecologically sustainable
well first of all thanks for having me
on the show uh
of course you're right that people
restaurants small businesses with
a lot of customer interfaces use more
disposables now than they
used to directly before the pandemic but
there's of course
also another part of the story and that
is that we saw a lot and see a lot of
changes of patterns of behavior and
consumption that actually move towards
more sustainability
starting with food in germany for
example the
consumption of regionally and
ecologically produced
food has increased during the pandemic
both beneficial for the environment we
saw lots of changes in mobility patterns
less business trips less commuting to
work more home office some of those
probably will be maintained after the
pandemic
and of course due to lockdowns which is
not a positive thing
for the economy and for the humans but
nevertheless consumption and production
went down and therefore also energy use
raw material use and therefore was
something where stress on the
environment went down so overall i would
say
um it's more the opposite that we didn't
see
patterns change in a way um that
are environmentally more destructive
although disposables is probably
one point where it did yeah so that's in
terms of
individual behavior but globally
can we say that this pandemic has been
good or bad for the environment
i think that rests still to be seen in
the immediate effect
as i said consumption production went
down um there was no air travel
for some time many factories went on
on leave pretty much put their people on
leave didn't work and
so it was like a pause for the
environment for the stress on the
environment
in most areas um and um but as a
it is with a pause button if you push
play again then the question is
whether the situation will be different
so that depends a lot on
whether companies and governments will
rethink their business models or their
investment um support and change things
for example in fashion
we've heard from some companies saying
they um
due to resilience questions of their
value chain will move away from fast
fashion
um in fast fashion is nothing else than
disposable fashion and therefore
detrimental to the environment if you
look at how much water cotton for
example needs and a t-shirt
so um the question will be how many
actors in the economy
and from the government side will change
their way of doing business
yeah in terms of governments as they
seek to
get economies going again what sort of
things should they be
bearing in mind well first of all it's
it's totally understandable that they
have to look at
um easing um the burden for put
particularly the social disadvantage
socially disadvantaged and that the
pandemic and the lockdowns
bring about at the same time now taking
money for recovery packages they should
look into
where they invest and there of course
they should invest in
more sustainable technologies we have a
lot of transitions in the energy sector
and the transport sector and the
agricultural sector and the building
sector
we need to move to a circular economy in
all these areas
it would be helpful and oriented towards
the future if governments
use their money to support business
models of the future that means electric
vehicles for example
in the transport sector that means
thinking about how to
encourage refurbishing of homes and
developing more sustainable construction
materials that means
um to move in the agricultural sector
away from quantity to quality
all these are things that they should
incorporate into their
recovery packages many do
more so than in the financial crisis
about 10 years ago
but still not enough if you compare how
much money goes into clearly
environmentally beneficial investments
compared to
the classical um business models then it
is not enough given the urgency that we
have in all those sectors
jan peter schemmel from the urco
institute for applied ecology thanks a
lot for joining us
and now for one of your questions to our
science correspondent derek williams
how hopeful is the drug interferon beta
when it comes to fighting covert 19
interferons are proteins produced by the
immune system that play a key role
in communication in the body during a
viral infection
they they warn cells that an invader
is on the loose giving them time to to
ramp up
additional defenses and there's evidence
that one reason
covet 19 can turn so serious is that
soros cove 2
seems to suppress interferon production
in some way early in the infection
process
the immune system is horrendously
complicated um the best description of
it
i've heard compares the many complex
interactions between different molecules
and cells
to to a ball of spaghetti so it's hard
to nail down
exactly what's going on but the
suspicion
that interferon production is being
turned off
that's led researchers to look at
whether giving interferons to patients
therapeutically might lessen cobit 19
severity
back in july a british company testing
inhaled doses
of an interferon called interferon beta
reported
in a small scale study that giving it to
early stage
patients cut their chances of developing
severe breathing difficulties
dramatically and it significantly
reduced their hospital stays
the company is now in further testing
with the compound
um other research indicates that the
timing
when exactly the signaling protein is
administered
that that could play a very key role in
how the body reacts to treatment with it
so
so to answer the question um researchers
are quite
hopeful that interferon beta will prove
as effective as
as early testing indicates but but we're
still waiting for more detailed results
you